all right let's do this it's time for
all things drama kevin all right let's
get into a drama series nominees
and let's start with bridgeton the
mandalorian lovecraft country
hands made tale this is us
pose the crown and the boys now in my
opinion and this is kevin frazier
speaking it is a two-horse race and it
comes down to the crown versus pose
because here's the thing the crown has
never won but
everyone loves the lady diana's story
and that's why i think the crown will
win um excuse me though but can we talk
about bridgertown i knew that was going
to be there we could talk about
bridgette i know that
i
i know
where are our veils
drew and i were obsessed with this show
yeah and we were not alone ross and i
rode that bridgerton horse until it
literally told us get off here we're
tired i got i got saddle burn
i love it what did you say
what do you say and it was worth it it
was so worth it
um and um you know this is this is tough
for me i'd like to turn to our followers
and see what they predict i hope they
give away
some love come on i know right
wow
i um i'm glad to see that broadcast
television is uh reigning supreme
because we're all on broadcast
television right right indeed we need
y'all to come
that means we can keep our jobs
all right
all right let's move on to lead actress
in a drama series i always love this
category yes and here are the nominees
michelle oh my girl uzo aduba nominated
for in treatment uh we also have olivia
coleman for the crown of course yes she
plays the queen emma corn elizabeth moss
for the handmaid's tale mj rodriguez
and our friend jeremy smolet for
lovecraft country um
you know i can't call it for this one
i'm serious guys i think that this could
be anybody's i do think that that you
know emma and olivia are going to battle
for this they could cancel each other
out they absolutely and that's why i
think mj rodriguez has a really really
strong change it would be it'd be so
deserved but it would also be so
historic yeah absolutely trans person up
there accepting that award would say so
much
and if the performance earned it that's
what i was going to say the performance
earned it i don't think it's easy to
predict this one but let's look at the
results of our social poll
oh boy
oh wow
run away
you know run away let's go
let's go run away let's go june now i'm
a little shocked because she has one
yeah
she has one but we'll see we'll see all
right finally lead actor in a drama
series here are the nominees kevin all
right let's run it down for you and
let's start with sterling k brown from
this is us
jonathan magers from lovecraft country
mean um josh o'connor
um reggae jean paige
and this will be
probably the only time he's nominated
for bridges because we know he's left
why you gotta bring that up
[Music]
and don't count him about that's what
i'm saying like we look at all these
other names but boy he was so good then
um of course matthew reese for perry
mason yeah
well here is who our followers voted for
tally it up let's see
sterling kate brown come on friends
come on friends and that's an
overwhelming sterling k brown
and he's won before yes he has he has
[Music]